und mir jetzt zugeschaltet ist
rechtsanwalt und kempkens herr kempkens
wir haben es gerade gesehen die polizei
in der wg geht recht strikt vor
jetzt muss ich natürlich sagen es ist
der ein gutes recht es gelten die regeln
aber so kurz vor weihnachten ist das
doch ein ganz kleines bisschen unnötig
oder nicht naja der busfahrer hat ja
auch nicht weihnachten und von daher ist
es schon wichtig da jetzt schon
einzuschreiten
denn wir haben in der vergangenheit ja
festgestellt dass gerade diese
übergangszeit zeiträume sehr schwer sind
auch schwer zu fassen sind irgendwie
nicht so richtig akzeptiert werden und
deswegen wird hier offenbar so scharf
umgesetzt eine sache die man auch sagen
muss er ist gelten ja gern 16
bundesländer wir haben den föderalismus
heißt in jedem bundesland gibt es andere
regeln kennen sie sich da als anwalt
noch aus wo war es gilt ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen ad hoc müsste ich auch
immer nachsehen was die einzelnen
bundesländer anbelangt weil es ja
wirklich es gibt ja nicht nur die bundes
regeln die länder regeln sondern es gibt
auch örtliche regeln denn die regeln
können auch örtlich gemacht werden da
gibt es also so tabu zonen da gibt es
auch schutzmasken zonen den auch
besonders eingerichtet werden und so
weiter im grunde genommen muss man
gucken bevor man auf die straße geht
muss man einmal googeln in der eigenen
stadt und wenn man die stadt köln zu
überschreiten will muss nur noch in der
nachbarschaft gucken das ist also schon
schwierig und genau das zeigt auch die
kompliziert dass im bußgeldverfahren
sein wird denn keiner weiß so recht was
gilt also man muss schon sehr genau
hinschauen
ich habs jetzt schon öfter erlebt dass
ich zum beispiel alleine in der
u-bahn-station steg ein mensch neben mir
dann mache ich dann auch mal diesen hier
maske runter um einfach mal ganz kurz
frische luft in anführungsstrichen zu
atmen wenn mich jemand erwischen würde
ich müsste sicherlich auch zahlen ich
habe gegen die regeln verstoßen aber es
war ja niemand um mich herum kann man
auch bei solchen fällen dann dagegen
ankommen weil man einfach sagt ja die
regel ist zwar da aber es ist jetzt
einfach sinnlos in dem moment ja das
kann man durchaus machen
man kann also tatsächlich dagegen
vorgehen denn so ein bußgeldverfahren
licht immer im pflichtgemäßen ermessen
der behörde und die behörde kann in
jeder phase quasi das auch einstellen
und wenn man hier wie sie das gerade
geschildert haben nachvollziehbar sagt
ich musste doch irgendwie luft schnappen
es war keiner um mich herum
dann werden solche verfahren auch wieder
eingestellt diese möglichkeit besteht
die werden zwar erst eingeleitet
dann bekommt man anhörungsbogen und in
diesem anhörungsbogen kann man das dann
beispielsweise vortragen viele verfahren
werden dann eingestellt wenn man ein
bußgeldbescheid bekommen hat man die
möglichkeit innerhalb von zwei wochen
dagegen einspruch einzulegen wenn man
sich eben ungerecht behandelt fühlt und
dann kann man das eben noch weiter
vortragen und dann geht die sache zum
gericht und ihr dann bei gericht geklärt
und meine erfahrung aus den vergangenen
wochen aus den vergangenen monat muss
man ja inzwischen sogar sagen ist eher
dass die gerichte solche zweifelsfälle
dann eher wieder einstellen weil das was
wir gerade gehört haben ja auch
verständlich ist und dann sind die
gerichte dann meistens nicht ganz so
scharf wie man so denkt wieder was
gelernt also und eine letzte frage habe
ich noch in dem beitrag wurde zwar
gerade gesagt herbert reul hat zumindest
gesagt dass die polizei nicht vorhat in
die privaten räume zu gehen und zu
kontrollieren dürften sie ist ein
theoretisch ja das dürfen wir durchaus
wenn er mich die gefahr besteht dass
sich dort ein infektionsgeschehen
ausbreitet so wie das beispielsweise
eigentlich wenn man so will schon immer
war wenn die party zu laut war dann
kommt ja auch die polizei und das wird
dann aufgelöst und das ist jetzt
natürlich auch corona bedingt der fall
wenn also beispielsweise irgendwo eine
laute party ist und der nachbar rief die
polizei
dann kommt die polizei natürlich und
macht kontrollen stellt auch die
personalien fest und dann ist es auch
möglich solche partys aufzulösen und
dann gibt es auch knöllchen erkennen
ganz vielen dank dass sie da für uns ein
bisschen mehr licht ins dunkel gebracht
haben danke schön
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren